well guess what Brian guess what happens
to Brian no no I know
do you have good news and bad news but
the old eyelids Oh your consultation
dude
that cost Papa two grand yeah that cost
Papa well it cost papa grand actually to
have a conference for them to looking at
goes you have nothing in reais would fit
and that goes to your now now turns out
Papa's got to do both both lids the
Bopper I'm low as you can do one yeah I
don't know how did this work oh you're
just gonna do one I know I'm gonna do
both lids but you do the bottom part too
you see oh yeah your other self well you
got a little sake sack here so you got
to tighten things up on both sides
that's a nightmare now this is the guy
Jason diamond who does the Kardashians
so I have you know hey can I have some
beautiful [ __ ] I hate to be shitty
every single Plus surgeon LA says that
no no he's on TV with it they they do
not have C yeah they do testimonials for
a beautiful life great guy [ __ ] great
guy played baseball University of
Rochester all four you're like God uses
a 6-4 6-4 handsome guy cool guy a good
like a guy who's just a cool guy le plus
surgeon but care but but I mean I get
why success which is cool you go he
comes in start stalking me you're like
this guy's [ __ ] great anyway kind of
one of us to be honest with you like you
know what I like a guy's guy you know
yeah anyway looks at me he goes like
this he looks amazing is turn this way
turn this way he takes a stick and he
kind of like catches a little fat and he
goes very straightforward very
straightforward have you in enough
yeah so do you have you see what he did
to Kendall Jenner I mean I'm sorry Kylie
they that's the great Italian from a you
know like it's it's the craziest [ __ ] a
sick white girl internat what she is now
yeah you think he's worried about your
lid now we're doing asleep dude
turn until they do the bag huh doesn't
get the nuts under his eyes done he's
from we have all that money book just
know he has like just he is like to love
handles underneath design well so and
and the other thing is O'Brien I
because what bride didn't realize but
you probably did cuz you're younger but
what Bryden realizes that all the girls
you see oh
the girls you see Ronit walking around
have had their faces contort now I am
when you say plastic surgeon surgery to
me I think a guy was in a car accident
he's got to have his face rearranged I
don't know what plastic surgery is but
plastic surgery now the [ __ ] they do
with it for anything fillers of your
eyes fillers [ __ ] Botox lifting
lifting your [ __ ] forehead taking
spots away they can do anything to your
face and so when you see this [ __ ]
you're like I start asking the nurse and
I said what what is she was listen to me
she goes area I was saying people get
this and she goes oh oh you offshoots
the College of me she was like what I
felt like a I was like I'm not I don't
want to do this I don't know that I want
to do this I mean I'm already getting
teased by my friends for doing my eyes
you know I can't wait for you dud and
but they can do everything they can do a
little surgical if I got a little
gobbler here they'll do a little
surgical suture pull it off his you ask
him now he said you know he feels like
pulled up a slot he's a dude you guys
are sore dies and we'll have you back
yeah yeah and I'll be back and if you
must a dick like what happens these
people is they start filled they do the
fillers they do they let be there hey
Puppet you'll be there I'm never gonna
be there guarantee you can get those
like they all right I definitely like
younger I'm doing it yeah you know we
can we in fix your chicken neck and the
next you know you're getting your neck
yeah that you caring value of and your
elbows pretty wrinkly what do you say we
take a few inches off your elbow you can
do it all
why not tighten up right oh but I don't
want to be that guy cuz nice truck a
little pasty white plants under his eyes
well why wouldn't you fix that if you
have all the money in the world you can
yeah you can you can easily easily
because it's adipose tissue I can do all
that [ __ ] you're just usin [ __ ] out
of post tissue words yours priceless
you're just tired I'm tired he said just
look less hi hon yeah I said I got the
show so I can't look you know just take
a little easy Steve he showed me what
he's gonna do I'm like alright but bro
obviously I'm naive obviously like the
[ __ ] they can do is nuts
like what did he give you any look there
you snitch on anybody no he's a dog he's
a professional but you can see he's got
all these people and you know I mean he
he's the doctor to all these very famous
people but the
you can do this but you can do this if I
look at you watch this if I'm like this
this is what I would do if I were hit
Mike oh you know what we're gonna turn
your nose oh no surgery's not happening
the ad take the markers to go now I go
how would you do some of my dad he goes
just a little filler they can do it all
Apollo yeah you look good maybe for a
few months and then it all starts to
cave cause robbery to six months
probably buddy goes this is strange
three to six-month concrete in our
[ __ ] eyebrows he becomes your best
friend well no no no hold on he's a bit
of a drug dealer he's different than a
drug dealer kids yes do your eyes well
you look great dude six months go by and
your [ __ ] eyes are hanging down like
drapes you gotta go back well then his
clientele is a lot of his young gals oh
yeah they want the facials they don't
want all this stuff I said Olivia so
he's doing like it's just so been so
mind-blowing to me it's so mind-blowing
I don't know any hit thing about this
I'm so naive to it and blood oh these
were all women in Hollywood do that he
also does facial reconstruction surgery
too though like he's he's the real deal
what that's that guy got his that guy
huh what'd that guy get done apparently
his cheekbones he's not the guy who was
married to too many Spears so he said
our signature hats I was just sort of
modeling his hat yeah the man the man's
a good businessman I'll tell you that
much oh but this town vanity is the gift
that keeps on giving
vanity you're getting your brows done
what's this guy Chris Appleton
hair influencer died peace he's a
good-looking guy he is dude I might be I
want to I'm gonna take that picture and
said dude you should be a doctor dr.
diamond I want to look like that guy
so for him you had mandibles now you
know how they do that hmm filler the
whole line they'll give you a jawline
and that
filler that right there is filler that's
so [ __ ] weird they put stuff in yeah
that'll last six months problem now you
go back in every six months when your
face starts going back to that you go
back in so they give women worse your
lines
well everybody you know bum well
everybody you know in Hollywood these
actors and actresses are doing that
siller's a hundred percent but I was so
naive I'm so naive to it I was like
Wonder Woman kiss her Jules no gal gadot
she's just beautiful when I've said
everyone well I don't know I don't know
personally but listen if you're an
actress in this town you get to a
certain age you're gonna see one of
these guys and there are about six of
them and you pay with it and you'll pay
and you'll pay what the charge you okay
yeah you pay what they charge or do you
got it you gotta get your fix it is a
it's the business you want to get into
if you want to make the big money let's
put it that way
well that's like the botched doctors so
that's another guy they're packed oh
yeah and iayúdanos job from him know you
and I say I we met him but you don't
remember we were in at Sundance
at chef dance member we had that dinner
yeah I was sitting next to him at one
point oh really
yeah shorter one the guy who is married
to Jackie Maloof and he was showing me
like he's a great guy actually I really
like that Camaros name but uh cool dude
and but he's on that show botched yeah I
remember they were gonna fix my ears
that's right oh well dude you got to see
where is that picture of I've kind of
wish I did it but no I like it
wait I gotta send you I gotta show you a
picture of what he'll do
yeah dude I mean everybody so the point
is I'm gonna be my facial from them oh
well now now hold on get our keys give
ok spritz my face well hold hold Casey
first bump bus take away that she looks
like Nick Nolte okay well they kind of
pulled her face out that's what they can
do now with your face it's it's the
nuttiest thing they can make your nose
longer
do anything I have no idea oh no no it's
not cheap they're just they're just
they're just trimming your brows up and
it's 11 G's yeah yeah but that that
standard actually that bets that can be
standard I did some shopping around uh
Afghan Venice two-for-one 500 bucks
yeah I'm not when it comes in my face in
my eyes I can't I can't have it bye we
didn't shop around
I can't botch it shop around look at it
but I found a Groupon yeah but there are
women walking around who are young women
who have $100,000 face mm-hmm yeah oh my
buddy's girlfriend she's 22 she's been
getting stuffed on her face and can't
tell but there's no wrinkles ever yeah I
thought that maybe she's a part agent
but she's Mexican and she's been getting
it done since she was like 17 like every
few months
the theory is notice yeah a lot of girls
that you don't yeah you just realize
that you cuz the theory is you know that
wrinkles or you don't
Botox you won't get ribs right you
freeze the muscles you can't move yeah
we do your forehead sweets but I'm not
doing it it's nice but hey man ah don't
say that let's see what dr. diamond
wants that's my doctor now dr. diamond
hey doctor dr. D dr. D dr. D how much
for a facial now so now the facials you
can get the inste facial which is like
they use plasma your own blood they do
all kinds of [ __ ] but the Kardashian
girls that's what they do once a month
and they swear they swear by the vamp I
can shave 10 15 years off someone's face
each individual tooth cost between
twenty five thirty five hundred so
veneers are probably the price is part
of the Instagram face equation let's
Instagram face no but that's true
veneers are expensive but yeah they pray
to shave off ten to fifteen years I mean
imagine me 15 years ago I don't think
they can do it as much for guys to girls
girls a lot easier now that I know a lot
about this the middle of your face
you can give me a jaw like quagmire this
is completely [ __ ] me up dude what hey
hey no I don't hate and I I don't want
to see a friend
I don't what just happened what if they
bought your eyes I'm just you come out
[ __ ] I'm not like Jeff Bezos and ones
like this but ones like a sniper
everybody's been warning me including
our lawyer he goes careful man
you do it the wrong come out looking
like a woman it is dicey with the eyes
don't cut corners I nice and lips
quarters on some things but not on that
doctor's gonna do your face out a friend
got her lips done and I went with her
she got it done right when she got him
done the first day I'm like damn that's
great they look super swollen like well
looks like get punched in the lip
two days go by gotten gone yeah no they
didn't last
oh that you might want on it and it
looked so painful cuz they take a needle
and jam it into a lip all like 30 shots
what now they do it differently oh do
their yeah yeah yeah now I have mature
you get that top lip hey dude
there's nothing wrong with having a full
mouth no I'm not doing any of that but
but now they're differently they have
like different materials that are softer
and all that stuff I mean it's a whole
it's a whole technology looks like your
dude I'm just calling drama girl no if I
don't have lips I'm why wouldn't you do
that there's nothing worse than a girl
with no lives you have no lips you got
to do something right yeah a little lips
of Michael Rapaport you got to do
something
yeah and that happens yeah man see
something about it yeah that's not bad
let me go away if you ever change your
mind it's not forever yeah
girls tattoo their eyebrows yeah I'll
tattoo their eyeliner facial contouring
is finale this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]